Dr. Zak, I'm so happy to see you.
Alhamdulillah.
May Allah protect you and your family.
My name is Hassan
and I'm an entrepreneur.
Regarding your topic, I see that many
Muslim in Indonesia are defied partly
because they have different views on who
is ulil Amar and to whom be bay is given
in this country based on surah and
some believe that this refer to the
president and government of this country
while other disagree they agree they
argue that the countries allows allow
non-Muslim to lead and the country
system is not entirely based on Islam
and sadly all of their reasoning is true
in Indonesia.
So in the end they choose to create
their own olyri and bay at them. My
question is who is the real Amry in
Indonesia and who has the right to be
given by in this country.
Brother the bay talking about is the bay
which is compulsory is to the Khalifa.
One is to the messenger. The messenger
will not come. So that baya is gone. The
other bay which is requirement is only
to a khalifa. There are different levels
of baya.
One is that the messenger comes you have
to do a bay and Quran speaks about in
surah ma chapter number 60 verse number
8. The other bay is to the khalifa and
khalifa is not based on country is based
on ummah. Do you understand? Other bay
is not compulsory. You can give bay to
your teacher you can give to a local
organization but those are not bay which
are there is no bay in surf of country.
In Islam there's nothing like country.
There's no division of country. We only
believe in um I think you heard my talk.
Um
>> yes.
>> So in Islam there can be only one
khalifa and not only of Indonesia of all
the Muslims in the world.
>> Now unfortunately the kilafat has been
abolished more than 100 years back. The
last was in Turkey.
>> Last was in Turkey.
>> Yes. in
about 102 years before
at
that time. So now inshallah we pray to
Allah that when the kalafa comes if the
khalifa is there then it becomes further
to give to the khalifa. The kalafat
hasn't been deinstated. But Allah says
there are many hadith that inshallah
before the world ends. The Muslims will
rule the world for seven years on the
base of Quran and had
and there are various there are signs of
the last day minor signs and major sign.
Your question is only invalid.
The ba of the khalifa is for the full
ummah full world not for a particular
country. Hope that answers the question.
And about kum sir. Uh
>> am can mean anyone. It can be a scholar
here. Am those of authority he may be a
scholar.
>> Yes.
>> Who is it? You have to find out. Some
are true some are not true.
And if okay you have someone who's
really a great scholar and you think
okay fine you have to follow. But the
the khalifa is common everywhere. the
other of your organization, the leader
of your organization, the leader of your
community, that depends upon you. There
is not fixed one person per se. Hope
that answers the question.